parlant de la campagne électorale après
stephen rapp eu hier soir c'était au
tour de ses adversaires d'être de
passage au québec aujourd'hui le québec
qui sera un terrain de bataille cruciale
dans le cadre de cette campagne
emmanuel donc un grand rassemblement ce
soir pour justin trudeau et bien sûr la
cible c'est thomas mulcair
oui c'est vrai que c'est la première
fois que le chef libéral venez au québec
depuis le déclenchement de la campagne
électorale et donc quelque 600 militants
qu'il attendait qu avait bien hâte de
l'entendre
les libéraux qui doivent absolument
faire des gains au québec s'il espère
gagner cette course
mais en même temps si les attaques de
justin trudeau contre le 50% +1 de
monsieur mulcair portes au canada
anglais ça risque pas de les dévier au
québec à court terme
vous allez voir pour le chef libéral le
message aux québécois est très simple
ils tentent de les convaincre que seul
son programme va leur offrir des
solutions concrètes à court terme par
les baisses d'impôts la prestation pour
les enfants plus généreuse
lui qui qualifie le programme de son
adversaire néo-démocrate comme un mirage
écoutez leur offrons nous aux québécois
un plan qui va permettre la croissance
économique qui va créer des emplois et
qui va mettre de l'argent dans les
poches des québécois coffre ton moqueur
une augmentation du salaire minimum que
vous ne toucherez pas un programme de
garderies qui est moins bon que ce que
vous avez déjà oui justement thomas
mulcair lui était aussi de passage à
montréal il lançait son autobiographie
un projet de longue date mais qui
évidemment un caractère éminemment
politique
oui c'est clairement une arme de plus
dans l'arsenal stratégique du npd dans
cette campagne électorale
vous avez le npd fait campagne sur le
changement pour ça il faut inspirer les
gens donc projeté une nouvelle image de
monsieur mike r comme un homme qui se
bat pour une bonne raison que le courage
de ses convictions et cetera ceci est
essentielle au canada anglais où il est
peu connu mais sa porte aussi pour le
québec
bon s'il vendra pour lui à relancer
encore mais on a remis encore une fois
sur les lieux de la sécurité questions
de sécurité terrorisme
c'est clairement le thème la semaine
avait l'économie la semaine dernière la
sécurité cette semaine sur les deux
piliers de leur argumentaire sur la
stabilité
si vous voulez et surtout on voit les
conservateurs faire des annonces
potentiellement controversée pour un peu
forcé leurs adversaires à les dénoncer
et après ça se donner les moyens de les
quatre de les attaquer comme c était de
s'auto manufacturés des munitions comme
leurs comptes leurs adversaires dans ce
dossier